JOHN ESSIGMANN: As I
mentioned, I'm diabetic.
And when things that
I noticed in my dad,
before he knew he was diabetic--
he'd come home from
the train at night,
and my sister and I would rub
his legs, because they hurt.
This is one of the
problems with diabetics.
His feet hurt.
And I remember my sister
Nancy saying once, gee.
Daddy smells like Mommy's
nail polish remover.
Which was acetone.
And acetone is one of
the three ketone bodies,
the other two being
Beta-Hydroxybutyric
acid and acetoacetate.
So what happens in
diabetes is, the diabetic
doesn't have ample carbohydrate
reserves within their cells
as glycogen. So they're doing
a lot of fatty acid oxidation,
rather than
carbohydrate metabolism.
If you take a fatty
acid, and you break it
down to Acetyl-CoA,
the last step
is called
Beta-ketothiolase-- backs up,
then your two
carbons of Acetyl-CoA
will be four carbons
of acetoacetate.
And then acetoacetate-- a
third Acetyl-CoA can add to it
to form what's called
hydroxy-methylglutaryl-coenzyme
A--
HMG CoA.
And then rearrangements
can happen
that give rise, ultimately,
to the three ketone bodies--
acetoacetate,
Beta-Hydroxybutyrate,
and acetone.
So in situations
where-- of starvation--
and diabetes is
basically, my cells
were in a technical
state of starvation.
In a case of
starvation, what happens
is you get this backup
of the lipid breakdown,
or catabolism pathway.
And then these ketone bodies
flush out into your blood.
In starvation situations,
the ketone bodies
will act as fuels for your
brain and other organs.
It's a difficult transition.
But ketone bodies are--
in the case of
diabetics, they're
produced to excess, to such
extent that they're actually
quite harmful to you.
The reason a person
smells of acetone
is the intermediate
ketone body--
the acetoacetate
basically decarboxylates.
It's a Beta-keto
acid, and so it's
a spontaneous decomposition
to form acetone.
Acetone is not, to my
knowledge, biochemically
useful as a kind of
an energy source.
But it's a sentinel,
or it's something
that is smelled, so that it can
be diagnostic of the disease.